depuis quelques années maintenant la
souffrance n'est plus jugée inéluctable
pour les malades il y a même des centres
hospitaliers sont de plus en plus
nombreux d'ailleurs comme celui de la
timone à marseille où un programme
spécial anti douleur a été mis sur pied
ce sont les malades eux mêmes qui en ont
la responsabilité reportage caroline
gauthier laisse aux florentins voilà
alors tout à l'heure quand vous êtes
arrivé après l'intervention médiatique
sur une échelle qui allait de 0 à 10 la
douleur était environ deux sets et demi
dès les premières minutes après
l'opération le mot douleur est prononcée
en salle de réveil désormais
systématiquement le personnel soignant
évalue la souffrance du patient dans
leur chambre ou du moins des objectifs
par rapport à quelque chose qui est
subjectif ce que tu as c'est
complètement fou et que la douleur est
individuelle
on ne peut pas prendre en compte son
propre et sa propre expérience ou dire
on est tous qu'il a eue celui-là il a
pas mal ou bon ça suffit quoi il est
vraiment douillet non ce sont des choses
pour pas en temps et le message commence
à passer la clinique de marignane
participe depuis le mois d'avril au
réseau hôpital sans douleur il réunit
plus d'une trentaine d'établissements en
provence son objectif
uniformiser la prise en charge de la
douleur pour cela la pompe à morphine
est un des outils et c'est le patient
lui même qui se l'administrer
et chaque fois qu'elle commence à sentir
la douleur est là puis avait cette bande
à mon fils c'est bien né puisque chaque
fois que je ressentais la douleur
j'appuyais sur le bulletin et ça me
calmer
autrefois
ce traité que les malades qui se
plaignait or il ya des malades qui
souffrent qui ne se plaignent pas et par
l'évaluation systématique en salle de
réveil on reconnaisse de douleurs et des
protocoles qui sont vraiment assez
simple on la traite systématiquement et
c'est à l'hôpital la timone à marseille
que médecins et infirmiers suivent une
formation spécifique pour cette prise en
charge de la douleur savoir l'après en
baisse à voir la mesurer et organiser la
réponse à sa présence sa constatation
manque maintenant les moyens financiers
l'initiative repose à ce jour sur la
seule motivation des équipes soignantes